wir können jetzt direkt sprechen mit
Ulrike Franke von dem European Council
of Foreign Affairs ganz liebe Grüße nach
London und vielen Dank schon mal dass
Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben sehr
gerne Frau Franke kommen wir eben zur
militärischen Lage dann fragen wir Sie
ganz einfach und Sie können das
beschreiben also in den letzten Tagen
haben wir gesehen in den letzten Wochen
eben ein sage ich mal Momentum dass die
Ukraine genutzt haben Tag für Tag neue
Berichte man hat so und so viel an
Quadratkilometern zurückerobert Dörfer
zurück erobert aber wird dieses Momentum
weiter genutzt kommt das Ganze zum
Stillstand oder wie geht es weiter
es ist natürlich sehr schwer
vorherzusagen Momentum ist unglaublich
wichtig im militärischen Operationen und
insofern dass die Ukraine es geschafft
hat nach diesen vielen Monaten des
Krieges jetzt eben das Momentum wieder
zurück zu erobern ist beeindruckend und
wichtig und erklärt Ihnen auch zum Teil
warum es diese wichtigen gesetzgewinne
gab das wird sich natürlich nicht ewig
so weiterführen lassen schlichen
ergreifend deswegen weil die Gebiete die
erobert werden müssen ja auch gesichert
werden der Ukraine fehlen natürlich
letztendlich auch noch mehr Equipment
auch die Ukraine hat natürlich sehr
viele Soldaten verloren diese diese
Operation der letzten Monate und gerade
die Erfolge der letzten Tagen und Wochen
dienten auch sehr dazu den besten zu
zeigen schaut mal was ihr mit den ganzen
Waffen die uns liefert was wir mit den
Waffen wie wir uns liefern auch
erreichen können das war insofern auch
ganz wichtig aber um jetzt da noch viele
Quadratkilometer mehr zu erobern das
immer so weiterzuführen ja wird die
Ukraine auch weiterhin mehr Waffen
brauchen insofern wir sollen jetzt nicht
denken dass das ist jetzt das Momentum
das geht jetzt immer so weiter und wenn
es durchaus sein kann dass da noch ein
bisschen was kommt aber letztendlich
werden die Ukrainer versuchen sich jetzt
eine gute Position zu bringen auch vor
dem Winter und bevor dann die Truppen
der russischen mobil Regierung auch auf
dem dem Kriegsgebiete letztendlich
eintreffen da wollen wir einfach mal
hören was der ukrainische Gouverneur der
Region luhans dazu sagt zu der
militärischen Lage und auch zu den
Zielen der ukrainischen Armee
nach der blitzschnellen Operation
haarkiff nehmen die ukrainischen Truppen
das Tempo nicht raus sie führen die
Gegenoffensive weiter sowohl in Richtung
hakif als auch in Richtung luhansk Don
jetzt herson überall kommen die Truppen
nach vorn vielleicht nicht so schnell
wie ein haarkiff aber sie kommen jeden
Tag voran
jetzt die Frage an die
Sicherheitsexpertin ist das denn
realistisch oder spricht da ein bisschen
mehr der Optimismus statt der Realismus
dass man also in alle Richtungen so
weitergeht denn sie haben ja auch gerade
gesagt irgendwie hat es die Erfolge
gegeben und es war ein Zeichen seht her
was man mit den westlichen Waffen
schaffen kann bedarf es nicht erstmal
mehr Waffen oder auch Nachschub dass die
Ukraine dieses Momentum fortsetzen kann
also diese Rückeroberung fortsetzen kann
mit solchen vorhersagen kann man diesen
Krieg ja eigentlich fast nur falsch
liegen es hat sich an diesem Krieg viel
getan was so nicht erwartet wurde
insofern will ich mir da gar kein Urteil
erlauben aber natürlich ist da auch eine
ukrainischen Seite in gewisses Maß an an
Propaganda und Messaging sowohl nach
innen für die eigenen Truppen als auch
nach außen dem unterstützenden Westen
drin es ist klar dass die Ukraine weiter
versucht zu pushen die will die UK Dinge
die will die die besetzten Gebiete der
Ukraine zurückerobern hat sie natürlich
auch jedes Recht zu aber ich würde schon
denken um das jetzt in diesem Tempo und
mit diesen Erfolgen die wir in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen gesehen haben
weiterzuführen ja wird die Ukraine auch
mehr und und weiterhin Waffen brauchen
daher ist es einfach wichtig dass der
Westen sich jetzt nicht denkt das hat
sich jetzt gedreht und wir können das
jetzt laufen lassen so ist es sicherlich
nicht Ukraine wird da viel versuchen
aber Russland bleibt weiterhin ein
starker Gegner oder zumindest eben ja
ein großer Gegner und jetzt gerade mit
der Mobilisierung von diesen 300.000
werden nicht mehr Soldaten bitte auch
noch einiges auf die Ukraine zukommen
selbst wenn das jetzt kein gut
ausgebildeten Soldaten sind
das ist aber genau eine Frage ist das
jetzt wird das jetzt die Gewichte
verschieben wenn 300.000 russische ja
Männer rekrutiert werden und dann an die
Front geschickt werden kann das jetzt
sozusagen den Ausgang eben auch
verändern
es kann den Ausgang verändern natürlich
also diese Mobilisierung
ist müssen als dass es eben von allem
was wir hören nicht gut ausgebildete
Reservisten sind die da jetzt an die
Front geschickt werden sondern teilweise
Männer die gar keine militärische
Erfahrung haben also man hat wirklich
den Eindruck da wird ganz krass gesagt
kann nun Futter rekrutieren aber diese
Zahlen wenn Russland es schafft jetzt
schnell auf diese Soldaten auf
Schlachtfeld zu bringen hat das
natürlich trotzdem einen Einfluss
300.000 und dann wird teilweise auch
mehr ist natürlich schon eine relevante
Zahl während der Ukraine mit jedem Tag
mehr
jeden Tag mehr Soldaten verliert
insofern da kommt jetzt ein bisschen auf
die Geschwindigkeit auch an es ist
ziemlich offensichtlich dass Russland
wirklich versucht diese Truppen sehr
schnell auf Schlachtfeld zu bringen also
da geht es um Training von nur zwei
Wochen das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht
ausreichend das bedeutet auch dass dann
die Truppen letztendlich wieso Partizan
Kämpfer irgendwie auf dem Schlachtfeld
noch trainiert werden aber sie sind dann
eben potenziell vor Ort und das kann
schon einen Einfluss haben
wahnsinnig viel Angst muss da jetzt
meines Erachtens ihnen nicht haben weil
das jetzt weiß Gott keine gut
ausgebildeten Spezialkräfte sind aber
Quantität hat im Krieg immer auf seine
eigene Qualität daher sollte man das
auch nicht unterschätzen nur weil es
hier um drucken geht die jetzt
vielleicht nicht besonders gut
ausgebildet oder auch besonders gut
ausgeschnitten
ganz kurz einfach mal diese
Teilmobilmachung läuft jetzt ganz
schnell die Referenten sind im ich sag
mal jetzt eine Windeseile durchgezogen
worden
was zeigt das Ganze im Westen wird auch
sehr oft hier gesagt das sei ein Akt der
Verzweiflung ist es ein doppelter Akt
der Verzweiflung von Putin
ich würde sagen es ist eine Eskalation
aus der Position der Schwäche
das macht es nicht weniger gefährlich
das macht es sogar noch gefährlicher
aber es ist ja schon so dass
die Mobilisierung etwas ist was was
Wladimir Putin nicht wollte und was
jetzt nötig geworden ist
wie gesagt es ist trotzdem eine
Eskalation das bedeutet trotzdem dass
die Truppen dann auf dem auf dem
Schlachtfeld sind das macht es
schwieriger für die Ukraine aber es
zeigt eben auch dass dieser dieser Krieg
in keinster Weise so läuft für Russland
wie sich Putin das vorgestellt hat
insofern würde ich das als der
zweischneidiges Schwert bezeichnen die
scheinreferenten und es ist wirklich
ganz wichtig dass wir betonen das ist
eine Bass diese Referenzen sind
völkerrechtswidrig das ist komplett egal
was da rauskommt das hat überhaupt
keinen Einfluss da geht es natürlich vor
allen Dingen darum Propaganda nach innen
zu betreiben also zum zum russischen
Volk und eben du suggerieren diese
Menschen wollen zu Russland gehören und
auch in Richtung Westen die die das
Signal zu senden das sind jetzt
russische Gebiete von Russland eine
Kirche Gebiete und wenn da die Ukraine
angreift und zurückerobern will dann ist
das ein Angriff auf russische
Staatsgebiet das ist natürlich
kompletter Unsinn das müssen wir
weiterhin betonen das ist kompletter
Unsinn aber das soll suggeriert werden
das ist die narrative und ja auch hier
das macht das Ganze wieder gefährlicher
insofern wir treten jeden Tag in eine
gefährlichere Situation in den Krieg in
den Krieg ein trotzdem können wir uns
natürlich über die ukrainischen Erfolge
freuen aber es bleibt dabei die ist noch
nichts gewonnen die ist noch nichts zu
Ende wir sind weit entfernt von einem
Waffenstillstand soweit ich das
einschätzen kann und ja insofern mit mit
Vorsicht da eben muss da getreten werden
jetzt haben wir über die militärische
Lage gesprochen jetzt ist der Beitrag
von Christian Volk auch mit Ton da über
die militärische Lage dann wollen wir
uns die Situation doch auch im Film noch
schnell angucken
ukrainische Soldaten angeblich im
Kleinen dorfried-dub in der Region
Donetsk die Ortschaft offenbar
zurückerobert die Gegenoffensive läuft
weiter das sollen diese Bilder zeigen
der Donbass hat für uns oberste
Priorität denn er ist immer noch Ziel
Nummer eins für Russland
Geländegewinne gibt es nach ukrainischen
Angaben vor allem östlich des Flusses
aus Kiel die Verteidigungslinie der
Russen durchbrochen mehrere wichtige
Verkehrsknotenpunkte wie die Stadt
cupiansk offenbar befreit doch selbst
dort gibt es noch immer heftige Gefechte
viele wollen raus aus der Kampfzone
wir kommen von der anderen Seite des
Flusses unsere ukrainischen Soldaten
kämpfen dort es wird so viel geschossen
in der gesamten Stadt cobiansk zeigt
sich die Zerstörung die Grausamkeit des
Krieges Einwohner sprechen von Folter
während der russischen Besatzung und die
Ukraine bereiten sich auf die nächsten
Gefechte vor
ja also soweit die Lage das ist eben wie
wir eben gesagt haben das Schlachtfeld
auf das Putin 300.000 neuer Rekruten
werfen will
das Entscheidende ist diese 300.000 wenn
er von der teilmobil-machung spricht es
geht ja nicht nur darum Männer in
Russland zu rekrutieren sondern eben
auch in den von Russland besetzten
Gebieten zu rekrutieren wir reden gleich
darüber schauen uns aber mal anhören
einfach mal was eben der Gouverneur Hadi
dazu sagt der ja sozusagen fern ist von
seiner Heimat weil eben die meisten
Teile von Johannes von Russen besetzt
sind der aber natürlich hört wie es denn
da mit der Rekrutierung aussieht die ja
letzten Endes dann dazu führt dass
ukrainische Männer gezwungen werden auf
Ukrainer zu schießen das ist das was
hadey uns erzählt hat
ist akut denn in einem halben Jahr
wurden fast alle Männer eingezogen
die Musterung wurde aufgehoben es werden
kranke und behinderte eingezogen
es werden selbst Männer eingezogen die
von Unternehmen gesperrt sind aus
kritischer Infrastruktur
was haben Sie zu befürchten dass sie an
der Front getötet werden denn die Russen
schmeißen diese neu einberufenen
Ukrainer unmittelbar in die Hölle des
Kriegs
ja in die Hölle des Kriegs wir haben es
schon gesagt und sozusagen das Blut
vergießen geht eben auch dann damit
weiter vor Franke wir haben jetzt
gesehen es also hatai hat beschrieben
wie fürchterlich das ist wenn eben diese
Männer rekrutiert werden aufeinander
schießen müssen dass der Krieg ja damit
eben weitergeht und weitergeht sie haben
selber schon gesagt gerade orakelnd ein
Waffenstillstand ist so schnell nicht zu
sehen ein bisschen Hoffnung des Westens
wurde ja auch darauf gesetzt dass jetzt
Proteste eben in Russland aufkommen wir
haben über die ersten Proteste berichtet
Frage könnte das größer werden könnte
sich die Hoffnung des Westens irgendwie
erfüllen dass diese Proteste dann am
Ende Putin so gefährlich werden dass es
dann eben zu einem Ende des Kriegs kommt
ich
glaube das ist
unwahrscheinlich
soweit ich in der Lage bin dass jetzt
von außen zu sehen aber auch ihr
Reporter in Moskau hat ja
treffenderweise gesagt solche
Protestbewegungen brauchen auch
Anführungen Führungspersönlichkeiten und
die sehen wir aktuell noch nicht in
Russland es ist sicherlich richtig dass
diese Mobilisierung jetzt den Krieg nach
Russland gebracht hat also in den Alltag
der Menschen bis hier die letzten 7
Monate war ja immer die narrative
spezialoperation und das machen eben
unsere Truppen da und das hat die
Menschen in Russland letztendlich wenig
tangiert das hat sich jetzt geändert
also sowohl in den großen Städten als
auch eben vor allen Dingen in den
Inventar Republiken wird rekrutiert wird
eingezogen auch eben wie wir gehört
haben Männer die überhaupt nicht wollen
dass das hat einen Einfluss und deswegen
regt sich Widerstand das mögen wir
begrüßen aber von allem was wir aktuell
aus dem russischen Regime hören
erscheint es nie jetzt erstmal
unwahrscheinlich dass daraus eine große
Revolution
entwickelt letztendlich kann man das
natürlich nie sagen und es hängt doch
davon ab wie Mobilisierung weiterläuft
wie der Krieg weiter läuft aber sagen
wir mal so ich würde da jetzt nicht die
großen Hoffnungen draufsetzen im Westen
dass sich das russische Regime das
russische regieren quasi von von innen
implodiert und sich dieser Krieg damit
regelt das erscheint mir erstmal
unwahrscheinlich
dann haben wir zum Schluss auch noch
eine Frage hier über youtube ist sie
gekommen von Chris on air hallo besteht
aktuell die Gefahr das ist noch mal eine
Entscheidungsschlacht geben wird so wie
es sie Anfang des Jahres in Kiew um Kiew
herumgegeben hat sie haben schon gesagt
die Dinge sind schwer vorherzusehen
viele Satz ich in diesem Krieg auch
anders entwickelt als vorhergesehen aber
wir erinnern uns eben da hat sozusagen
Russland alles in die Waagschale
geworfen ist gescheitert man kann sagen
die große Schlacht um Kiew eben verloren
ist es möglich dass es irgendwie eine
derartige große Schlachtern eben im
Osten oder Südosten eben geben wird
also das ist noch mal zu einer
Entscheidungsschlacht kommt das ist
absolut möglich ich würde allerdings
aktuell vielleicht eher in die andere
Richtung gehen das ist eine
Entscheidungsschlacht sein könnte dass
eben die Ukrainer vielleicht eine ihrer
wichtigen Städte zurückerobern können
die Frage ist wie viel kann Russland
tatsächlich noch in die Waagschale
werfen und von dem was wir jetzt sehen
und kann leider immer nur sagen so genau
können wir es nicht wissen und da ist
viel Unsicherheit drin aber von dem was
wir sehen erscheint es mir sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass das Russland es
schafft sich jetzt in der in der
Hinterhand so zu organisieren und so zu
mobilisieren dass man da wirklich noch
mal signifikant drucken und zwar eben
gut ausgebildete Truppen und Material
etc aufbringen kann um noch mal ein ein
Großangriff auf also auch hier von sagen
ja sowieso nicht aber auch andere Städte
zu fahren leider immer mit der mit der
Klammer es ist schwierig woher zu sagen
aber ich erwarte das jetzt eigentlich
wirklich eher nicht meines Erachtens
gerade die Situation dass beide Seiten
also Ukraine versuchen zurück zu erobern
aber aber vor allen Dingen russland
versucht sich jetzt auch in der Position
zu bringen die sich gut verteidigen
lässt gerade vor dem Winter denn im
Winter ist jetzt wahrscheinlich dass ich
das ganze noch mal etwas verlangsamt und
ja das eben russland versucht Gebiete zu
halten die ist jetzt hat solange es kann
um da ja wie jetzt gesehen haben und wie
auch ihre Sendung angefangen hat eben
Fakten zu schaffen Fakten zu schaffen
mit solchen Referenten diese Gebiete zu
besetzen sie als Russisch zu bezeichnen
an zu annektieren und somit auch auch
die Rückeroberung noch mal noch mal
schwieriger zu machen
und Frau Franke das führt genau zur
letzten Frage die man einfach heute an
dem heutigen Tag stellen muss sie sagen
Fakten schaffen es geht um das Ziel das
haben wir deutlich gemacht dass eben die
russisch besetzten Gebiete der Ukraine
einfach völkerrechtswig eben annektiert
werden aber das Russland dann eben sagen
kann das ist Russland wenn die Ukraine
versuchen diese Gebiete zurück zu
erobern dann wird Russland angegriffen
das haben wir deutlich gemacht und heute
hat der Ex-Präsident mit WDF der eben
stellvertretender Vorsitzender des
russischen Sicherheitsrates ist noch
einmal heute ganz frisch gesagt russland
hat das Recht wenn nötig Atomwaffen
einzusetzen das ist schon mal gesagt
worden aber heute hat er das noch mal
wiederholt und auf die Frage ob das denn
auch die Position des Kremls ist hat er
dann eben auf hat der Kremmen Sprecher
peschkov auf die militärische Doktrin
Russlands verwiesen das ist immer die
Möglichkeit eines nuklearen gegenschlags
oder nuklearer Schläge vorsieht wenn
eben russisches nicht angegriffen wird
müssen wir denn jetzt ernsthaft damit
rechnen dass in diesem Krieg wenn die
Ukraine weiter versuchen ihr Gebiet
zurückzuerobern das Russland dann eben
taktische Atomwaffen einsetzt
es ist natürlich wahnsinnig zynisch also
Russland droht ja schon länger eben mit
mit dem Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen in
diesen Krieg die gute Nachricht in
Anführungsstrichen ist dass wir nicht
sehen dass Russland seine nukleark
Kräfte in Position bringt dass die
mobilisiert werden also da hat sich
außerhalb der Rhetorik nichts getan zum
Glück aber diese Position zu sagen wir
greifen fremde Staatsgebiet
Staatsgebiete Ukraine an besetzen das
eine Tieren das deklarieren das als
Russland und wenn man dann versucht ist
zurück zu erobern dann sagen wir das ist
ein Angriff auf Russland und wir haben
das Recht Atombomben zu zünden oder
nuklear zurückzuschlagen das ist
natürlich
wahnsinnig zynische Politik und dem dem
dürfen wir überhaupt nicht
recht geben dass das dürfen wir so nicht
akzeptieren das ist völkerrechtswidrig
das ist absolut inakzeptabel die
nukleare Gefahr natürlich muss man sie
immer mitdenken weil wir es mit einer
nuklearen Macht zu tun haben es ist aber
auch nicht so dass uns das komplett in
Starre verfallen lassen sollte auf die
Ukraine nicht wird auch die Ukraine
nicht es ist auch militärisch wenig
sinnvoll für Russland Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen man muss mal die Frage
stellen was wollten Sie denn angreifen
was ist hier die Überlegung also das ist
militärisch nicht wahnsinnig sinnvoll
aber natürlich die Rhetorik ist da die
muss mitgedacht werden Russland spielt
da ganz klar mit das macht das Ganze so
so schwierig und so unangenehm aber wir
dürfen dieser narrative nicht nachgeben
das ist jetzt plötzlich dass diese
ukrainischen Gebiete jetzt russisches
Studium sind und das Russland jetzt
irgendein Recht auf diese Gebiete hat
und irgendein recht sie dann wie auch
immer nuklearde anderweitig zu
verteidigen